So, specialist, let me go ahead and do
it like this. There you go. What's up,
man?
>> What's going on?
>> What's going on? You disagree?
>> My bad. Yeah, I disagree. God wants to
be identified as one, not not the
Trinity.
>> Okay. You believe Jesus is the father?
>> What?
>> You believe that Jesus is the father?
>> No.
>> What do you believe about Jesus?
>> Yeah.
>> Jesus is is God. The Holy Spirit is God.
The God the Father is God. But he don't
want to be identified as three.
>> But you said Jesus isn't the father.
>> Jesus is God. God the Father is God. The
Holy Spirit is God. But God does not
want to be identified as three.
>> Is Jesus the same person as the Father
or is he a different person?
>> They're they're different.
>> So you believe in the Trinity?
>> No, I don't. I don't believe in the
Trinity. I just said that. He does not
distinct person.
>> God does not want to be identified as
three.
>> Okay.
>> So So John John First John 57.
>> Oh, hold on. Hold on. First John 5:7
says,
>> "Specialist, hold on a second, dude. We
got you. Let's Let's work this out
together. Okay. All right. These three
are one. We get it now.
>> No. No. Hold on.
>> You say You say that the Father, the
Son, and the Holy Spirit, these are
three distinct persons that share the
same one divine essence. Is that what
you believe?
>> I I believe what John 1 John 5:7 says,
"For there are three that bear record in
heaven, the Father, the Word, which is
the word, which is Jesus, the Holy
Ghost. These three are one." It don't
say these three are three. It says these
three are one.
>> All right. But are there are are there
three of them though?
>> What do you It says it right here. These
three are one.
>> So there's three in one. There's three
in one sense and one in another.
>> What what do you mean by that?
>> So when it says these three, what are
the three?
>> These three. The three are like John f
first John 5:7 says, the father, the
word which is Jesus, the holy ghost.
>> Yes, I got you.
>> Those three those are the three. These
three are one is what John says. It
don't say these three are the trinity.
>> How are they three?
>> What do you mean? How are they three?
>> It says these three. How are they?
>> I I don't know what you mean by that.
>> So if the you're saying that they don't
want to be identified as three
God does not want to be identified as
three.
>> So is John wrong when he says these
three?
>> What do you mean wrong? No. John John is
not wrong. He says these three are one.
>> So how are they three?
>> God the God the God. Okay. So, Lord,
Lord, when in the in the beginning when
it says um
>> No, how are us? Lord, Lord, capital L,
capital O, capital R, capital D. Take
care, man.
>> He's a Trinitarian. He don't even know
it, bro. Bro,
>> what's up, Rick?
>> Hey, what's going on?
>> What's up, man? You disagree, man?
>> So, I feel like the last guy kind of
ruined it for me. However, I don't
disagree, but I do have questions to
clarify a few things because I've been
thinking and I watch you a lot, Avery,
and you seem to be the most logical
thinking person when it comes to this
subject.
>> Okay? So, cuz this is for people who
disagree. Yeah, this is for people who
disagree. However, that's why I needed I
could tell you this. I I have streams
where I let Christians on to ask their
questions or to converse. If I let you
if I let if I let you on and do this,
all the other people that I told no to,
it'll be unfair. And the other people
who's going to come up and try to jump
on even though I've already said, "Hey
guys, please don't join if you agree.
Let the people who disagree join." So
that's kind of a disrespect to the
stream. So I got to be consistent. You
understand what I'm saying?
>> Yeah, I I understand. But I the question
was just challenging you know the the
whole idea of the
>> I understand and I'll go if if you know
if you want me to go but the question I
have is challenging you know the whole
idea.
>> Okay. So that's what I'll tell you
again. Come on the I'll I'll announce
it. Come on the stream when I allow
Christians to come up. Okay.
>> All right.
>> All right. God bless you bro.
>> All right. You have a good one. You too.
>> Yeah. Guys um let's I don't know if if
I'm not clear. I don't know what it is.
I don't know what it is. The link says
join only if you disagree. I've been
saying to join only if you disagree. And
uh a lot of you guys don't care. So when
I start kicking you without hearing you
out, I I don't need to hear no man
logic. Logic is just arrogant. And man,
logic you're so is disrespectful. I've
been very clear uh a thousand times. So,
for the people who are going to continue
to disrespect me in my stream because
you think that what you have to say is
more important than what I just laid
out, you're just going to get blocked
and banned. It's as simple as that. So,
I gave I gave Rick that last that last
chance, that's it. The next person that
comes up and you agree, you will be
banned. Simple. I'm not even going to
hear you after. If after you say, "Yeah,
I agree, but there ain't no butt."
You're out of here. So, respect the
stream, my brothers and sisters. I
shouldn't have to waste time of the in
the stream talking to y'all like this. I
shouldn't have to do that.
>> That's real.
>> All right.
>> What's up, man?
>> I'd like to say shalom. Shalom. Can you
guys hear me?
>> Shalom. Yes. Do you disagree, man?
>> Absolutely. Yes, sir. First, I'd like to
acknowledge both of you brothers. Thank
you, God Logic, and thank you, Fearless,
for giving me this opportunity. I've
I've had uh people recommend that I come
on this channel and speak to you. So, I
like to say I like to stay on topic and
I like to address the first question. I
believe Jesus is not God. I don't
believe that anymore. And also the
Trinity. I do not believe the Trinity is
true. Not anymore.
>> All right. So, let's get into it. So, do
you want Jesus created?
>> Well, do you want me to address
question? Do you like cuz that's my
first time being on here. So, do I
follow your questions or can I, you
know, inject a question?
>> So, so we just we just talk, bro. We
just have a conversation based off what
you said. So we'll ask you a question
based on that and we just have a
conversation from there and you can ask
questions in the middle of that you know
however that goes.
>> Yeah, this is my first time so I didn't
really know how this works but yeah I I
like to go to the Genesis if if you'll
mind the the the foundation of the Bible
which is the the Torah to be technical
the the uh the the five first five books
of the Bible the prophets
the writing name and name. Yeah.
>> What about Genesis? No, no, no. I like
to go to the foundations. What I meant
to say the beginning. So like when I
look into the quote unquote Old
Testament, right? Which is really called
the Tanakh. It's not called the Old
Testament. It's called the Tanakh, which
contains the Torah, the first five books
of the Bible, the Kesh, then the which
means the prophets, then the Ketuim,
which means the writings. So I just want
to address that by saying when I look
into the quote unquote Old Testament, I
don't see Jesus. I don't see Jesus
existing. I don't see the pre-existence
of Jesus. Also, I don't see the Trinity.
So, um,
>> do you do you believe in
>> my analysis, by the way? I'm sorry.
Sorry. I didn't mean to cut you off. I'm
sorry.
>> Yeah. Yeah. Just to be just to be clear.
So, you do you believe in both the
Tanakh and the New Testament?
>> Uh, the Tanakh, yes, the New Testaments
on trial, respectfully.
>> All right.
>> When I say on trial, it just depends. If
it if it if it lines up with the Torah,
with the Tanakh, I rock with it.
However, some of the writings from Paul,
I do not rock with. Uh, I do not rock
with at all. women. It's off topic, but
I just want to say this. Paul, he um he
says that women are not allowed to teach
and lead. I totally disagree with that.
And I'm a Hebrew Israelite saying that.
>> That's in a That's a That's in a church.
That's in a church setting.
>> Yes. Specific church, by the way.
>> Yeah. It's not law, right? It's not law.
So, I don't have to follow it as an
Israelite.
>> Oh, sorry. Sorry. I was
>> So, you do believe me.
>> You do believe in some of the New
Testament.
>> Yes. It just depends. It's case by case.
>> Got it. Got it. I'm talking about the
Old Testament. That's fine.
>> Okay.
>> Yeah. So, the Old Testament, if you guys
can uh prove Jesus is God. And when I
say God, I'm talking about not just a
man with power, woman. I'm talking about
the most high
>> like Yahweh.
>> Yes. Yes. And also, can you gentlemen
also provide sources, verses I prefer
that prove that Jesus is God in the Old
Testament and also that the Trinity is
true?
>> Yeah. We'll go point that with the
audience for education, please.
>> Yeah. We'll go point by point. So, first
we can go to Jeremiah 23:5 and 6. All
right. It says, I'll read it while he
pulls it up. Uh, it says, "Behold, the
days are coming, says the Lord, that I
will raise to raise to David a branch of
righteousness. A king shall reign and
prosper and execute judgment and
righteousness in the earth." So, first
off, do you know who this is talking
about?
>> Well, it says king. It never said most
high God. It said king. It says king.
That's not my point. I'm not even at my
point yet. I'm asking, do you know who
this is talking about yet?
>> I'm listening here. I'm I'm listening.
>> It's talking about the Messiah. Do you
agree?
>> Yes. This is a this behold the days are
coming and declare yeah which not great.
Yeah, this is like a messianic figure
but it says king.
>> So for context it doesn't say I haven't
got to my point yet. All right. Verse
six. In his days Judah will be saved and
Israel will dwell safely. Now this is
the name by by which he shall be called
the Lord which is Yahweh our
righteousness. So why does it say to
call the Messiah Yahweh our
righteousness? Well, you also got to
keep in mind that Hebrew names are
theophoric, a lot of them, and they have
the name of God within them.
>> There's Yeah, but there's no person ever
called the fullness of the
tetetrogrammaton in the Old Testament
besides the Messiah. Nobody.
>> Well, the Well, you can find the
tetetrogrammaton within the names of of
Hebrews is what I'm saying. Like,
>> you can find parts of it. So, for
example,
>> yeah, like you find the shortened
version like Yah is the shortened
version. Y is the short version.
>> I'm saying this is actually the full
tetetrogrammaton right here, though.
It's not within a name. He is actually
called the tetetrogrammaton. Can you
call anyone the fullness of the
tetetrogrammaton that's not Yahweh
himself?
>> And you also got to include that name.
It's it's it's tricky. It's not just
like English because name in Hebrew
shame or shame.
>> I'm asking a question though. So can you
>> No, but I'm I'm actually addressing your
question, you know. I mean, hey, I mean,
I don't mean to be disrespectful, but
I'm just giving some context that like
when you come in the name, a Hebrew
name, it contains authority, a
reputation, um character. So I just
wanted to to keep that in mind that yeah
it says that but also we find the name
Yah whether if it's the full version or
the shortened version and technically
throughout uh if we want to look at
history if we want to look at uh the
history of the name Yod Wah before it
was four letters it was three letters
that's why you seeing some names like uh
Yahoo for example
you cut me off please you're giving us
something that we already know you're
giving
>> I'm actually giving edification to the
audience cuz the audience doesn't all
know this we shouldn't
>> actually answer the question though at
hand I'm answering the question by
saying that give me a contains yo which
three letters it's the first rendition
of the question whether if it's three
letters two letters or four letters
Jaden Jaden Jaden what was my question
>> go ahead and repeat it
>> no what was my question
>> go ahead and repeat it I'm here
>> my point you don't even know what I said
you're answering a question you don't
even know what I said I'll say it again
now and I want you to actually answer it
is anyone or can anyone be called the
fullness of the tetra grammaton in the
old testament that's not the most high
god You know what? I'll just be honest
with you with you. I'll have to go ahead
and check that out because I'm
objective. I I don't like to make claims
without just just saying it cuz it's
possible. I I don't know. Uh fearless.
That's a good question. But what I will
say is that names throughout our
language throughout Hebrew are
theophoric theophoric names. I'll give
you an example when it speaks about uh
there's so many examples. Uh Kazaka or
uh uh when it speaks about Isaiah 9:6.
>> Yeah. uh an everlasting father, but it's
it's speaking about many people
interpret that to be the Messiah, but I
interpret that to be uh King Hezekiah.
>> Yeah. Okay, that's that's fine. But
yeah, so there's no name in it. The
point is though, you will never find
someone called the fullness of the
tetetrogrammaton that is not the most
high God besides the Messiah. The point
is that's because the Messiah is able to
be identified as the most high God.
That's the point. Okay, that's your
inference and that's your inference and
I I totally respectfully disagree. But
to me, this is not definitive hard
evidence that proves that this king,
this messianic figure is the most high
God.
>> Well, that's fine. You can agree with
that, but you'd have to show me any
evidence of anyone else ever being
called the fullness of the tetra
grammaton at any
>> we can go through. That's what I'm
saying. Like you're relying on this
fullness like on this technicality. But
what I'm saying is when we say
hallelujah, do we have to say hallelu
halleluah or can we just say hallelujah?
Are we saying the same thing or we are
we saying
>> my point No, my point is though is that
the only person that's ever applied the
fullness is ever applied to is God.
There's a reason for that.
>> Okay. So So was his name the Lord of our
righteousness? Was was Jesus called
that?
>> Was he called what? The Lord our
>> righteousness. Yeah. So So that was the
name that he went by when he lived 2,000
years ago.
>> No, that's one of the names that they
called him. He had
>> So it's a nickname. So it's an empathet.
>> What? No, he
>> empathetic. So, how come you just didn't
say that, Fearless? How come you just
didn't say this is an empathet? This is
a nickname.
>> That's not what it is. It's not just a
nickname. His name
>> His name was His name was No, his name
was Yeshua Bar.
>> He also has a name written on his thigh
that no one knows but himself. He has
multiple names just like God in the Old
Testament has multiple names. They
didn't all call him Adonai. That doesn't
mean that wasn't one of his names.
>> Yes. Like I said though, Theophoric
names are found throughout the Hebrew
Bible. Just like the example I gave,
yahoo.
Theophobic and that's older than Yode
Wahi. That's what I'm saying. Like
historically speaking, we can look this
up. This isn't an historical record. The
Shashu people actually knew about this.
The Shashu people uh worshiped they they
knew the name of Yodi Wow. We find the
records in Mits in Egypt. So I'm just
giving context that before it was
Yahhei, it was Yodi Wow. So I think
you're relying on this technicality, but
to me I'd like for you to provide hard
evidence. To me, this
is difference. I don't see it.
>> This is the point. The point is that
only God and Messiah are are talked
about as Yahweh. They're the only two.
That's the point. But we can move on to
the Trinity as well if you'd like. If
you don't have
>> Absolutely. Yeah. This is not proof at
all.
>> I want to show something.
>> Sure. Go ahead.
>> Okay. Um, who do you who do you take the
son of man to be in Daniel? Uh, J.
>> Uh, Israel or and also when I say
Israel, not just strictly Israel, but
those who uh who who love Israel, those
who are part of the nation because I'm
an Israelite that believe salvation is
for everybody.
>> That's cool. You're talking about the
son of man though specifically the son
of the son of
>> that's what I'm like to go with I like
to go in go logic I'm just saying I like
hey I got to know keep it simple though
keep it simple
>> but we on the same well I mean I'm
bringing good energy you know you feel
me but yeah Daniel 7 is speaking about
the son of man is it's a vision where
Daniel he needs help with the
interpretation
>> and brother brother brother that's why I
was say I said keep it simple who is the
son of man and Daniel said
>> oh yes yes I'll answer that again yes
and in Daniel 7 in that context in the
original context God logic I believe it
is uh the the the the it says the the
believers of or the followers of the of
the most high it's like in Daniel 7:26
or the answer is there
>> it says it says that they the the
followers of the most high are going to
be serving this son of man so
>> bring that out yeah absolutely yeah
recently
>> I got it's all good I saw in the night
visions and behold with the clouds of
heaven there came one like a son of man,
right? So, there's one person here was
like a son of man and he came to the
ancient of days and was presented before
him and to him was given dominion and
glory and a kingdom that all peoples,
nations, and languages should serve him.
His dominion is an everlasting dominion
which shall not pass away and his
kingdom one that shall not be destroyed.
So here the son of man is the king who
is who has everybody else as his
subjects. Everybody else, all people's
languages, everybody in the world are
subjects of him, right?
>> I follow.
>> So this would have to be the Messiah,
right?
>> Not not necessarily.
>> So then who is this?
>> Okay, let's start off from the top. You
said like a son of man. Let's go there.
Um can you open up the tools that way we
can show the audience what the Aramaic
saying? The
>> Aramaic?
>> Yes, it's written in Aramaic. You think
the oldest is in Aramaic?
>> Yeah. Part of Daniel's, the book of
Daniel, fearless, part of it is written,
most of it's actually written in
Aramaic.
>> The oldest we have is Hebrew.
>> Yes. But this right here is Aramaic. And
I'll show you. I'll show you. It says
like a son of man. This is for education
for the audience. To me, it's not about
winning or losing. It's about
edification for the people. That way,
they get to see both sides of it and
they can make their their decision, you
know, themselves. I like to have people
to think for themselves. Now, it says
like a son of man. Um, yeah. Yeah. Go
ahead. Scroll down for me, please.
>> Going to make it bigger. Yes. Uh that
word um uh enosh
is what I'm looking for. Enosh like a
son of man. I'm showing this on I'm
showing this for a reason because it
says in the King James I'm glad you guys
don't have the King James. A lot of
Hebrews mistakenly just rely on King
James and that's it. We got to do better
than that. But it says uh you guys
translations you guys brought up got it
right. It says like a son of man. This
is uh Enosh. This is uh Daniel 7:13.
That's right. brought it in. So this is
like a son of man. This is not the son
of man. So that's
in mind linguistically. Fine. Who is it
though?
>> No the word the first letter.
>> Who is this respectfully? Look who is
this please.
>> Okay. You want me to get to it? Okay. I
just wanted to just just just to to say
that this is not the son of man. It's a
son of man. Now let's go down.
>> We don't need that. We know who
>> I'm answering. This is my answer. Just
go below please. This is my answer. Go
below to verse 27. I'm giving you the
answer by the scripture. No, I need I
need this right here. The one who comes
to the ancient of days approaches him
and is given a kingdom and dominion. The
one whom all nations including Israel is
serving the people of God are serving
the son of man.
>> Who?
>> My answer is the scripture. Go down to
verse 27.
Tell us who this is. Okay.
>> Yes, sir. Yes, sir. Because he got a
vision. Daniel's trying to figure this
out. He doesn't understand. The kingdom
and dominion and the greatness of the
kingdoms under the whole heaven shall be
given to the people of the saints of the
most high. His kingdom whose kingdom
>> so the most high's kingdom, right?
>> Yes.
>> Shall be an everlasting kingdom and all
dominions shall serve and obey him. So
the son of man is the most high whose
kingdom is an everlasting kingdom who
whose uh kingdom the saints dwell in.
Correct. I like to thank I like I like
to I like to thank you for showing the
scripture because this is my answer. The
saints are the most high. That's the
answer of the saints. That includes
Israelites and non-Israelites. So, thank
you for showing that God logic. I
appreciate that. That's my answer.
>> So, so the saints, who are they serving?
>> The most high yacht and only the most
high yacht.
>> Okay. Okay. According to verse 13, who
are they serving?
>> Well, verse 13 is it's a vision and he's
trying to figure it out. This whole
thing is a visionual. This whole thing
is a vision.
>> In verse 13, who are they serving?
Please. I mean, you're giving me these
hard yes or no answers, but I have to
give some kind of context if you don't
mind. That way, we can understand like
it's not just one individual
>> in verse 13. Hey, Jaden, I'm going to
give you one more chance. Who are they
serving in verse 13, please?
>> Okay. First, there's more than one
individual. There's other individuals.
>> Well, you left him on longer than me. Oh
my gosh.
>> Yeah. Take care of yourself, man.
>> Try not to answer final box. Oh my
goodness.
>> Yeah, take care of yourself, man. Go on
and get get give that wisdom somewhere
else, man. I'm pretty sure somebody out
there will listen to you. Wow. Wow. Wow.
Wow. All right. John Joe, the bond
servant.
>> You hear me?
>> You guys uh y'all disagree?
>> Yeah. Now, it's it it's more like a
semantic thing. Before Before I even
get, I just want to salute you, my
brother. Um you one of my favorite dudes
to watch. You and um Sam Shahoon. Y my
dudes, man. Like Yeah. I definitely
learned a lot from y'all. And um one
thing you said earlier that I want to
focus on is uh I ain't trying to debate
with you, bro. Like if we going to
debate you one, but the word says we
reason with each other, right? So I'm
coming here to reason with y'all. Now I
believe that the three is one, but I
don't believe the three persons. I
believe it's one person. Like you just
read in Hebrews 1:3, Jesus is the image.
Oh, pardon me, I lost my breath. Jesus
is the express image of God's person,
not persons and not personhood. It's his
person. And in Genesis 1:26 when he
said, "Let us make man in our image." I
believe that there's one image between
the three. There's one person, one
spirit, one mind between the three. So I
believe that the three are in Christ.
Not that they're three people that we're
going to see.
>> What What are they? What? What are these
three? Three. What?
>> Now that that's why I said it's like a
semantic thing. That's why I don't
really want to debate with you and be
like, "Nah, I don't I just can't sign up
with the word person because person I I
got you. So, but we do got to if we're
going to eliminate the concept of
person, we got to we got to substitute
it with something." When you're saying
that the three three the three what?
>> That's that's a good question, brother.
That that now I can't I I don't got
another word for it. So instead of
instead of trinity, I would say godhead,
right? Because I believe I believe it's
in Christ.
>> Well, God Godhead I feel like Godhead
just means the divine nature. So and I
of course the divine nature dwells
within him bodily. The Godhead dwelt
within him bodily cuz he is fully
divine, right? He's fully God and fully
man.
>> Yes.
>> However, this still doesn't account for
the other per uh you don't want to use
persons. That's why we That's why it's
clear to us that they're persons because
you you're going to have to you're gonna
have to tell us what they are. What you
father
>> I can stay with that. I I can stay with
So I got I got a question.
>> Do you believe they have different
images?
>> No, they have the same image.
>> Okay. Okay. See, I'm in agreement with
you with there.
>> So that that that's that's my whole
thing. And that's why I think with this
it's a little tricky because some people
who say you know I believe in the
trinity they say that the three people
the three images but they're in perfect
essence and they work perfectly
together.
>> I never heard a trinitarian say that
there are three images but you know that
that would be that would be incorrect.
>> Yeah. That that that's that's where I'm
like this is where I'm like wrestling
with this word. Like I'm not I'm not
saying oh if you say I'm a trinity oh
you're wrong. You're going to hell. I'm
not I'm not saying none of that. I'm
just like where really is your belief
and I'm thinking
>> so the reason the reason why we say the
reason why we use the word person is
because the the word person signifies
you know uh agents with a mind you know
uh with a will with emotions
self-awareness that's what personhood
is. So we're saying that the father,
son, holy spirit because they have a
mind yet it's one mind.
>> Um they have a will. It's one divine
will that they share together.
>> Um you know they are self-aware. They
have emotions, right? Love, compassion,
stuff like that.
>> So they are persons. However, they they
are distinct in their personhood. The
father begets the son, right? The Holy
Spirit is is brought forth from the
father through the son, right? The son
send the son sends the the holy spirit,
right? From the father who proceeds out
of the father.
>> In his name. In his name. Yeah.
>> In his name. So we we can clearly see
that there is a distinction in who they
are as far as their person. The son, the
father, the spirit. That's the
distinction. However, they are one,
divided, inseparable within their
essence, within their godhead, within
the divine nature,
>> within their image. So, so, so, all
right. So, tell me if you with me on
this, cuz what you just said, I'm not
disputing. I that's that's, you know,
where my belief is. So, now what I
believe what I believe is is that in
that one image is where the three
resides and this is where Christ is
reconciling us back to him. That's why
the only way we could get back to that
that reconciliation is in Christ. Do you
believe that?
>> I I believe that I I believe that he's
making us right with with God and the
standing of our righteousness. Um when
you say getting back to him, what do you
mean by getting back to that?
>> Okay. I I believe Okay. Um if if we just
go to the beginning where it says in
Genesis 1:26 and 27 where it says, "Let
us make man in our image after our
likeness." Now obviously in his image
and after our likeness that's two
separate things. The word in means to be
surrounded and enclosed by and the word
likeness means to resemble or have same
characteristics. Right? So I believe
when he says we were made in his image
like I'm in this room. I'm not on it.
I'm not like it. I don't look like it.
I'm in the room. So I believe we were
made in God. I believe God is a place. I
believe in him. Ephesians 2:20 says he's
the chief cornerstone. The building is
fitly in fitly framed in him. We're his
building that grows thy temple in him.
He's our refuge. He's our habitation. So
I believe it's literally in Christ. And
in in second I I have a different
understanding of that. My the the way
that I understand being in the image and
after his likeness, I I believe that uh
that that is a it's what you would call
um um what what is it?
not not anthropomorphic, but it's a
reiteration like it's saying it's it's
more or less saying the same thing.
Being made in the image and likeness of
God is the same thing. It's not
something that's totally different.
>> Yeah, I agree. Yeah. Image and life
should be the same.
>> You believe you believe when he says in
his image and after his likeness, you
believe that's just one thing.
>> Yeah. I believe it's one thing that's
just being reiterated. So, so, so
similarly to how like what's an example,
Nick, of when we when we're making a
point and we say one thing and then we
reiterate that same, we make that point
stronger by even using a different word
that's a synonym or making the same
making the same thing and saying the
same thing.
>> If you could think of an example like I
I understand what you're saying. I I get
what you're saying that that it
>> like anything can be used that way. Like
if you say like this like this car is
like it could be anything. This car is
like super nice, nice and uh exotic.
Like this is going to be the same. Like
it could literally we use that every
day. It's just a normal thing to say.
>> Yeah. Yeah. If I were to say this K this
car was made very nice and exotic
>> and exotic. Yeah.
>> Yeah. Yeah. Yeah.
>> We're saying the same thing cuz all
exotic cars are nice.
>> I get what you're saying now. Now I I
have a different perspective on that cuz
you know like the word says we get line
upon line precept on precept. I can't
just grab that out of Genesis and just
say this is what it is because this is
what I believe. But if we if we go to 2
Corinthians 5:19, right? He says God
>> Thank you.
>> See, so God was in Christ. So I see that
God was in this place reconciling the
world unto himself because it's one
self. It's one image. So the father is
in Christ waiting for us. That's a place
that isn't made with hands that you can
only get there by faith. So now that
we're there, he reconciles us. doesn't
impute our trespasses onto us and give
us the word of reconciliation. Now, that
word reconciliation kind of proves that
point cuz how can you be reconciled to
somewhere or to someone that you never
knew before? So, obviously Christ came
to that.
>> Yeah. So, there's a slight thing that
that I'm disagreeing with you on, bro.
And the only part in what you said that
I'm disagreeing on is that you're not
making a distinction between the father
and the son. That's it. If you if you
can see the distinction between because
the son is not his own father.
>> No, I definitely do see that there is a
distinction. I definitely see. So if if
there is a distinction exactly
>> so there are these three they are
distinct,
>> right?
>> And but yet they are inseparable in
their essence. They're inseparable in
their divine nature. They share the same
one divine essence.
>> Yes. So that's what the trinity teaches
is that these there are three if you
want to get you know more more you know
uh deeper with it hypoasis there's more
there are three hypoasies or persons
that share the same one divine essence
that are inseparable in their nature
okay so yes the father reconciles the
the world back to himself through the
son by the spirit right they all have
their operations in their sal in this
salvific work. They all have their
operations or their jobs that they do
and the way that they function. They
have their own functionality when it
comes to the work that they do, right?
And so I I I would say that and that
that's Bible. The Bible teaches this. So
don't shy away from you know uh you know
submitting to the Trinity concept
because that's that's what the Bible is
demonstrating. Of course, you're not
going to see the word trinity there.
>> Yeah. Yeah.
>> But you're going to see that teaching is
that that's what it is. It shows that
the father, son, and spirit are distinct
in their personhood, right? In who they
are, while at the same time being
inseparable and united perfectly in
their essence.
>> Yes. No, I'm I'm in agreement. And
that's why like, like I said, I've been
watching you for some time and this is
the first time I actually even try to
log on like the download app and all
that just to get on because I was just
speaking about this in uh in in my Bible
study. How it's like the word trinity.
It's like we can't judge people because
of that. People say, "Oh, because you
know there's so many different beliefs
behind that." But it's really a heart
posture thing cuz I believe me and you
are believing the same thing. We're
saying the same thing. I just I have a
problem with that word trinity because
certain people who have explained the
trinity to me. It's three it's it's
three people that I'm like it's not
threeheaded god. It's not not a
three-headed god. It's just three it's
three persons. Three who's share the
same divine essence. One will one mind.
That's what the Trinity is, man.
>> Amen. So, so I'm in agree I'm in
agreement with that. If that's if that's
what you believe is the Trinity, I
believe that. And and and I can't
>> I could attest that I'm not going to
argue that. Now, not everyone who says
they believe in the Trinity does not say
that though. That's just
>> not not everybody is good at
articulating.
>> But, uh this is what the Trinity is.
>> I do have one question for you. What
what do you believe is the name of the
father?
>> Yahweh. Yes, it's Yahweh.
>> Yahweh.
>> Okay. So, I don't want to I don't want
to know this isn't the topic, but I
would just like to dig with you on
Isaiah 96. I know you guys notice this
where I see I see that a little
different. I'm not I'm not disputing
that Yahweh is not the name of God. That
is the name of God. He got many names
and that was the name that was revealed.
But how I kind of added on and put this
was saying with you and Sam same I
brought up in Proverbs 30:4 how they was
how the author was saying um who
ascended to or who who who
>> what is his name and what is his son's
name?
>> Yeah. What is his name and what is the
son's name? So now obviously the author
did not have it. He had the name Yahweh.
He had the name Elohim. He had the name
Elshad. He had King of Kings. He knew
all the other names but there was one
name that wasn't revealed. So he's
asking if you know it tell me. So then I
believe in Isaiah 9:6 when he's like
unto us a child is born, a son is given,
his name shall be called the everlasting
father. So it's clear that the Messiah,
that son that was born, his name is
going to be called the everlasting
father.
>> Well, everlasting father, Abiad in the
Hebrew just means that you were like the
the eternal sustainer. So when he's
saying that his name right he is the
everlasting father Abiad he all he's
saying is that this person who he's
speaking about is the eternal sustainer
of all things.
>> Yeah. Okay. Now we can't look at it in
that way now how the other kid was
saying one that was talking he was not
answering none of y questions is just
trying to show how much knowledge he
had. But he did say one thing that was
on point. The word name in Hebrew means
um your reputation. It means your your
your authority, your cause, your
characteristics. So what you also quoted
earlier in Philippians 2:5 where he's
like um let this mind be in which is
Christ who came in the for of God but
made himself of no reputation. So Christ
didn't come the son didn't come in his
own name and he clearly says that in
John 6 I come in my father's name right.
So because he humbled himself to the
lowest possible he humbled himself unto
death meaning he denied himself first
and then he died on the cross. God
highly exalted him and gave him a name
which is above every name. and gave him
a reputation which is above every
reputation.
>> Exactly. That's what that is. So when
you're talking about name in certain
context, it has to do with authority,
reputation, status, um your character,
stuff like that. So that's that's what
name theology is. So it wouldn't
necessarily be referring to an actual uh
something that everyone calls you, but
it's what's your what's your reputation?
what you're saying
>> like like like the brother just shared
that he got another name written on his
leg that no one knows and there's going
to be another name written on the stone
but I know for the name of the father it
had to be revealed and in John 176 when
the son was talking to the father he
said father I manifested your name to
the men which you have given me so we
need to know the name of the father and
he needs to manifest it
>> yeah but that but in that context it's
talking about god's character he's he
made the father known to them he made
his character, his his his uh his
nature. He made him he made the father
known to them. And so in that way, he he
revealed to them the his the father's
name,
>> the father's name. And then that's why
if we if we go a little more down in
that same chapter in verse 11 and 12
when he's like, "Father, I'm no more
with you. I mean, I'm no more in the
world. I go to you, but keep them in
your name." And he says, "While I was on
earth, I have kept them in your name."
That's why I go again to the surrounded
and enclosed by. So I believe that name
Jesus Christ is the name we have to
reside in. This is our refuge. This is
our habitation.
>> But see see again you're you're you're
you're appealing to something that is
like somebody's what he's called. It has
right here. It's not has nothing to do
with what he's called. It has to do with
his character, his power, his authority,
his status. That's what that's so and
keep them in your name. That doesn't
mean that they now they have the same
name as as the father. No, it means that
they are kept within his authority, kept
within his power, kept within his hand,
right? And protected.
>> No, I do believe I I do believe that
because that comes hand in hand with it.
But this is what Paul said also.
>> Last last point here and then I got to
>> All right, last point. I got you,
brother, cuz I know I am drifting. But I
do appreciate you allowing me to to
bring this to the table. Um Paul did say
I bow this is why I bow my knees unto
the father of our Lord and Savior Jesus
Christ whom the whole family on earth
and heaven is named. So this is our
family name. This is the name that keeps
us together. Like I love you because the
name you claim you understand you claim
the name. Well, okay. But I appreciate
your time, bro. God bless.
>> You believe in now though. God bless,
man. Appreciate that. Yo,
>> bless. God bless, man.
>> Hey, God bless you.
>> Yeah. Traran now. That's all that
matters.
>> Yeah. All right, guys. Come up if you
disagree. If you disagree, you're
welcome to come on up. Tofi, you're uh
let's try this again.
>> Hello. Can you hear me?
>> Oh, yes, I hear you.
>> Hi everyone. Good evening. I am Tofi. I
am from Morocco. I am Muslim. I am
interested about Christianity and I have
a few question I want to ask and please
bear with me. My English is not the
best. I hope you don't use big words.
So, so I can understand please. We'll
>> try we'll try our best.
>> Okay. My first question. My question it
is the I know I read the I read a little
bit of the old testaments and the new
testaments and the god said I am I am
the beginning I am the end I am the
alpha I am the the omega and stuff like
that when when he said that this mean
Jesus Jesus and the the holy spirit was
him when he was with him from the
beginning. Yes.
>> Yeah. But when I when I read when I was
looking I found out the devil through
like how I know the devil if you want to
attempt someone he attempt a human
prophets he go to attempt him to to take
them away from the religion or the god
away like how happened in Abraham that
depend on the Quran. Abraham he tried to
sacrifice his son the devil show up to
him to stop him told him we believe in a
god who told you to sacrifice.
>> You said Abraham had to sacrifice his
son and then the devil showed up to him.
Yes, that's what we believe in
>> the Oh, I think depending on the Quran.
Yeah, he showed him to stop him from
sacrificing his son. But that's why
that's why in if you go to Mecca, that's
why they shoot that rock on that thing
because they trying to do like how
Abraham did to the devil because he shot
rocks on him. They threw rocks on him.
>> What does that got to do with the topic?
Uh my question is uh the devil tried to
attempt uh tried to attempt uh Jesus but
if Jesus was there from the beginning
that's mean he was there when the devil
created he was there he was witnessing
the devil when the god created the devil
and the angels he was there that's mean
the devil on my understanding and I'm
sorry
knew him mean he knew him how he have
the audacity to go at time to god that's
>> because the same the same way that he
had the audacity
to go against him and to be kicked out
of heaven because of that. Because the
devil has no sort of humility. See, the
one thing the devil doesn't have that we
can have right now is humility that he
cannot copy. That's why. And no matter
no matter what, he's always going to not
have humility. He's always going to do
things that don't make sense.
>> Does mean you feel the devil can't go
try to attempt to go?
>> Yeah, he's he's dumb like that. Yeah.
>> No, he didn't. He just didn't listen to
him. He never did Gucci attempt him. He
got kicked out of heaven, right? Because
he was jealous.
>> He got kicked out of heaven because he
was jealous because he wanted to be
higher and he was he saw that the
humans, right, were going to be in union
with God and he wanted to be higher than
the humans. So, he had an issue with
that. So, he tried to overthrow
everything. So, he got kicked out, which
was dumb. In the same way, he's still
tempting people like Jesus who is God
because he's dumb. He does dumb things.
>> Okay. And my other question is uh if do
the if the the God the son the holy
spirit was there from the beginning did
god mention them to to Moses did he told
them in the old testament?
>> Yeah.
>> Can you show me where please?
>> So uh I mean he's talking about if the
holy spirit and the son were mentioned
to Moses.
>> Oh.
>> So I mean there's a multitude of verses
that we can go to. Um we can just start
off I mean by showing first of all that
God was multi-personal in the first
place. even to Moses. If you read
Genesis 1 26, God makes it clear that
he's multiple persons when he says, "Let
us create man in our image." In Genesis
1:26,
>> can you give me a sle look for it?
What's the number?
>> Genesis 1 verse 26.
>> I'll put it up on the screen for you. I
can I can put it on the screen for you
so you don't have to go off. I'll put on
the screen. To
>> that sounds like you got a computer
open. It's actually good. Here we go.
>> See it? Then God said, "Let us make man
in our image after our likeness." So he
made it clear to Moses that he's more
than one person here.
>> It us in our image. Can can can I read
can like if I if don't mind him asking,
can you show it to him in Arabic if you
can?
>> I don't think I can.
>> Yeah, probably not. I don't think
there's like readily available.
>> The names is different. We don't have
here. We don't see.
>> You might be able to find one.
>> Yes. This is an Arabic tank here.
>> Yeah.
>> Make it big. I don't I can't see. Oh,
hold on. Make it even bigger. Go. So, I
don't know where the
>> Yeah, because he was talking about how
the good create the earth and
everything.
>> Is it in here? Cuz I don't I don't I I
wouldn't be able to tell you. Is it in
here somewhere?
>> I need to read all of it, but I know
that take time. I will go look for it
when I when I have the time. But thank
you so much. My other question it is
Jesus said he's from the the woman means
he said the woman that's mean is like
from the family of David he's like
>> just really quick hold on what what does
this say here
that mean the good created the the human
on his image depend like his image
>> this man know Arabic this man got like
no Arabic that's crazy
>> I a different breed I swear
>> oh that's that is crazy so so what so
what does it
That means he created the the people
like his image.
>> And so does it say that that he said let
us make like in the plural like let us
make in our image.
>> No, he didn't say that mean he created
the image. He did the action and he
didn't make a human like his image.
>> Okay. So it doesn't necessarily
>> really can tell. I don't know Arabic so
I can't tell. I can't tell either. I
just I I just was able to just see this
>> and like let me What about this one?
>> My my next question is he said the Jesus
said he's from from David. He's like
>> oh wait hold on really quick. Sorry.
>> I got you. So he made man in his image
and like this. So that would mean what
if we go what does what does this say
right here? Sorry. What does this say?
means the good seed that is beautiful
and he say we we create we create
and and we and we create the god on our
and we create the people on our on our
image.
>> Yeah.
>> They go they go after I am trying to
translate and they go after the fish in
the sea and after the after the birds.
H. So this so this one this one said
where it says that God said let us make
man in our image and after our likeness
right?
>> Yes.
>> Okay. All right.
>> But in Arabic in Arabic there are a
slice different. In Arabic if someone
bigger than you like the king like royal
royal you call him in a royal word. And
when you call him you call him he's one
but you call him as many people.
>> Yeah. Ancient Hebrew don't work in the
same way that Arabic does though.
>> Okay. That's what it was written in
originally is ancient Hebrew. So,
>> okay. Thank you. Thank you.
>> So, so this shows that God is a
plurality of persons even in the first
chapter of Genesis.
>> Okay. Thank you. My last question and
I'm good to go. Thank you so much. My my
last question it is he said is this from
he said
minestly David and that's in Arabic
means like if I have grand grandkids
those those grandkids is belong to me
that's mean they have my genes and they
have I pass everything to them and Jesus
claim to he is from David that mean he
have his genes as is from his blood but
he's god how he can be from the blood of
of David and David is a human
>> I don't understand the question He's
he's asking how how can how can Jesus if
he's God, how can he also be a
descendant of David?
>> Oh yeah, cuz that's just in reference to
his humanity. So we believe Christ has
two natures, a human nature and divine
nature. So in accordance to his
humanity, his human nature, he comes
from the lineage of David through his
mother.
>> Okay. Thank you so much.
>> Appreciate it everyone.
>> Yeah. Come back again if you have more
questions, my friend.
>> Thank you. Thank you. Have a good night
everyone.
>> You too. God bless. Okay. So that was uh
Tufi